ben roethlisberger before we take a
break yeah we got to talk about this
because
there was some news last week while you
were off kevin colbert the team's gm
non-committal about roethlisberger chris
i i have a feeling this isn't going to
end well nobody wants to be the villain
they want to find a way to back out of
this but i think for the steelers the
analysis is very simple
we don't think the team around him is
going to be good enough to justify
continuing this another year i think
that's what they're trying to figure out
and if they think the team isn't going
to be good enough they're going to say
let's just go ahead and remove the
band-aid now let's take the salary cap
hit and let's start planning for life
without benefit
it does i hear you i think there's i see
that as well i i
first thing i would say is i don't i
can't imagine ben roethlisberger i don't
think he's going gonna like
shop himself and try to go play anywhere
else i always got the sense
that it's gonna be pittsburgh or that's
it and he's done you know
i think he's very comfortable he's not
gonna go learn a new system and offense
and do all that we know that
that's just not him he just wants to
play he already knows his offense and he
wants to just go
i don't think that's in his dna to want
to do that and
i agree with you pittsburgh's in a tough
spot here and he is not the guy that
you got to play a certain way with him
right now at this point of his career
so there has to be a certain support
system there and yes
i i think how they can figure out what
they're gonna do in free agency in the
draft
might dictate a lot about what happens
with big ben
because this he's not gonna carry a
young squad or a bunch of new pieces
and make that offense great by carrying
them that he's past that point in his
career
i just had a thought we got to go to
break but bruce aryan's giving his old
pupil a call saying come be tom brady's
back up and win another super
bowl and you'll be the young guy in the
room by about four or five years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports